Just before we jump into the video today,
I do want to say that this guy is a gentleman,
his name is John Hub and I hope I'm pronouncing that right Germans,
but I do want to say for all of the viewers today,
I'm probably going to screw that up at some point.
I'm probably just going to go with calling him John,
rob,
because it's easier for me to pronounce rather than trying with the whole thing
for the whole video.
So that's that out of the way.
Let's get into it.
What would you think of a man who supported the greatest mass murder machine in
human history?
A man who was proud to stands by a genocidal dictator who nearly destroyed
Europe,
a man proud to call himself a Nazi.
What do you find him sickening or evil?
Well,
maybe not.
If he was John Rob high ranking Nazi.
Rob was an ardent supporter of adult Hitler,
but he was also something else.
He was perhaps the greatest humanitarian that you've never heard of,
known as the Good Nazi of Nan.
King Rab was the third reichs man in China when the capital felons and Japan's
German aligned forces faced with the imperial armies genocidal actions.
He did something wholly unexpected.
He tried to save the lives of every Chinese civilian in the city.
Over six incredible weeks,
John Rob stood at the epicenter of a bloodbath,
single handedly protecting nine kings residents from a well winds of rape and
murder.
He is today credited with saving 250,000 lives and deeded all of this while
still staying loyal to adult Hitler.
Today we delve into the fascinating story of history's good Nazi.
When Joan Rob was born in Hamburg on November the 23rd 18,
82.
It was into a world that was on the cusp of a dramatic change just a year before
the rising state of Germany had delivered a surprise knockout blow to France in
the Franco Prussian war for rob's contemporaries.
That men's growing up at a time of unbridled optimism,
not that rubbed salt marsh have it taken out of school as a young age when his
ship captain and father suddenly died and stuck into an unhappy apprenticeship.
Young John was a boy,
always hoping to escape Germany and see the world,
and so he did in 19.
Oh,
three.
The 21 year old rob set out for the Portuguese African colony of Lutheran qualm
mark now,
and the pewter in Mozambique,
it seems he planned to stay there long term,
but an outbreak of malaria forced him to resend it to Hamburg after just three
years for John.
This was a blessing in disguise back in Hamburg.
He met up with an old school crush named Dora and was delighted to discover that
she was into him to the two quarter.
They fell in love and became these sickening German version of those loved other
couples who can't spend a single second to pause if John has been a slightly
more average man,
well that would've been it,
but John,
he wasn't San Fridge despite looking like a Nan cast by a which to forever
resemble a certified accountant.
John Rob had an adventurous soul three years in Africa.
It simply hasn't been enough for him.
So in Nineteen Oh eight,
he presented Dora with a plan.
The two of them would move to Shanghai rather than ask if a new lover Gone Mad.
Dora replied with the early 20th century dramatic equivalence of how yes,
neither of them could have known they'd chosen to move to a kingdom on the verge
of catastrophe.
On November the 15th,
1,980 to the dowager,
empress 60 breathed her last in the imperio gardens of Beijing.
The power behind the throne in China since 18,
65,
her passing left the ching dynasty dangerously unstabled already left reeling by
the recent boxer rebellion.
The family that had ruled China over 250 years at that last,
it's matriarch.
16,
was replaced on the threatened by her two year old pui and spoiled her and I
said,
don't bother memorizing that name as the aftershocks of sixties death rumbled
through Chinese society,
John Andorra,
they were entering a new era of their own in 19 Oh,
nine.
The young couple married in 1910.
John got a position as a clerk in a Siemens office in Beijing.
It was a position that will allow them to rise up quickly through the ranks,
becoming a pillar of the German ex pat community.
It was also a position that would give him a front row seat as China exploded.
That's an old Chinese curse that goes,
may you live in interesting times.
Well Times in China.
They were certainly about to get interesting.
On October the 10th,
Nineteen,
11,
the city of Wu Chang exploded in rebellion against the emperor boy.
This lit the fuse on roughly a bazillion of a powder kegs,
and in no time at all,
half of China was in revolt known as the zing high revolution.
It ended when six year old boy you abdicated in January of 1912 ending the Ching
Dynasty for a revolution that closed the door on 2000 years of imperial rule,
the sing high revolution.
It went remarkably smoothly.
China was declared a republic and you on Chicago became its head like most other
German ex pats.
Gentleman,
Dora Rave,
almost totally unaffected by these southern changeover of power.
However,
the same cannot be said for the next problem that was going to afflict China and
out of course was world war one.
Okay.
At this point,
we probably need to backtrack a little for a quick historical explainer.
For about 300 years before their abs had arrived,
China had been the most powerful nation in the east.
Then in 18,
53,
a guy called Commodore Perry led a fleet of ships into Edo Bay just outside of
Tokyo and threatens to blast the city into rubble and less Japan opened up its
economy.
The result was the opening of Japan under the Meiji government,
good news for American trade.
Very bad news for China.
This new Japan.
It quickly became a regional powerhouse as China lumbered along and also find
Japan started throwing its weight around like a sumo wrestler,
receiving electroshock therapy in 18,
95,
Japan even warped Beijing and the first sign of Japanese war.
This was an epic humiliation for trainer and it got even more epic when Germany
took advantage of China's weakness to occupy Qingdao in 18,
97,
setting up the German Shendong when World War One to finally rolled around.
China was eager to reclaim the stolen territory.
Unfortunately,
Tokyo,
they weren't done humiliating them just yet.
And late 19,
14,
Japan in Britain joined forces to invade chandon kicking for Germans out.
One of Tokyo's conditions for joining the fight was the China wouldn't be
allowed to get involved.
The allies agreed with China castrated as effectively as a unit.
Japan gobbled up a small territory taking south Manchuria.
In the war's aftermath,
the allies pressed China to officially seed Shendong and south Manchuria to
Japan.
Japan was further empowered and China was further humiliated perhaps in
response.
Nineteen,
19,
sore trying to kick out.
It's German expats including John and Dora.
Rob,
despite having lived in China for more than a decade,
suddenly they were personas non grata the death of president you on Chicago back
in 1916 had by 1919,
triggered a collapse of Chinese society known as the warlord era with China
Balkanizing into competing states constantly at war with one another.
The city is desperately needed.
Foreign expertise to stop themselves from including before 19,
19 was even out.
John Andorra.
Rob had been but grudgingly invited back in
the warlord era.
It came to a close in 1928 when nationalist troops led by Chiang Kai Shek
succeeded in reunifying China by force.
They established a new capital and non king beginning something called the
[inaudible] decade.
It was a time of prosperity that China had not seen since before World War One,
the economy,
it boomed,
stability,
rains,
and people's lives improved.
Among them was John Rob throughout the warlord era.
This quiet gentleman,
businessmen hood plugged away with typical central European efficiency rising
through the ranks of Siemens Asian division,
even as China crumbled all around him in the boom times of the Nanking Decade,
Siemens Made Rob Managing Director.
If it's Chinese division,
it's a license.
John Andorra,
they moved to nanking in 1931,
but 1931 was also the year that the wheels started to come off the new era.
On September the 18th,
Japanese forces used the pretext of a terrorist attack in south Manchuria to
invade Manchuria proper,
setting up a pro Japanese puppet state under our old friends and per a per year.
Rather than fight this new aggression,
the Chinese did something that probably seemed smart at the time,
but in retrospect does look a bit stupid.
They took their case to the League of nations set up in the wake of World War
One.
The League of nations was meant to settle disputes between nations without the
need for war.
In fact,
though,
it was pretty weakened toothless.
When it concluded the Japanese had been wronged to invade Manchuria.
The Tokyo delegation stormed off rather than cool tensions.
The League had actually raised them the things they wouldn't explode just yet.
Back in then,
King John,
rob was becoming the most important westerner in all of China.
In 1934,
he opens a German school on his property and made himself the chairman.
This brought you into contact for the first time with the Nazi party.
I'm saying,
yeah,
of Hitler had become Germany's unchallenged dick data,
and yes,
the emphasis on the first syllable there was fully intentional in this doc,
new world being a public German to figure being a Nazi even if you lived in
China,
but this wasn't a problem for rob already loved Nazi-ism.
Historians struggled to reconcile the humanitarian.
John Rob with the fascist drawn rob,
although he joined the party late in 1934,
rob quickly became one of Hitler's biggest cheerleaders.
He wrote of the regime,
I believe not only in the correctness of our political system,
but as an organizer of the party.
I am behind the system 100 percent.
Remember,
this is a man who had many Chinese friends who consider China his home,
and Harry was throwing his support behind a system that considered the Chinese
inferior.
The best gas historians have is that Ray does an ex pat 5,000 miles away from
home,
was unaware of national socialisms racism.
At the same time,
he was enthused by the socialism part with its emphasis on protecting the
dignity of the working man.
Whatever the truth relevant soon rose up the ranks of the party and became the
leading Nazi and Nan King.
It was arise that would come inside with one of the worst atrocities in modern
history.
On July the seventh,
19,
37,
a skirmish broke out on the market,
Podo bridge between Chinese and Japanese forces.
It was just one of many such clashes that happens following the occupation of
Manchuria,
but this time something went wrong.
The kind of progressed into a battle and the battle progressed and do a Japanese
invasion and the invasion of that progressed into a wall.
That's right.
The second sign,
Japanese,
will it adjust begun and it would make the first one look like a bit of a stroll
in the park,
right from the off.
The imperial army steamrolled across China.
In no time at all.
They were converging upon nanking as Balm,
as rains,
fiery death down on the city.
All of those with money,
they flat among them were John and rob,
who joined a tight of western is streaming away for the relative safety of
places like p Tire,
but Joel and Dora,
they were never ones to lay low and avoid danger on September the 20.
First,
they pretend to nat king as John would later write in his diary.
He didn't just to protect his property because he felt he had a duty to his
Chinese employees and his where we get to the really difficult part.
Rob Didn't return to help nanking in spite of being a Nazi.
He did it because he was a Nazi,
as hard as it might be for us to stomach.
It was the ideology of Nazi-ism that made rob feel that he had to stay
protecting his Chinese workers as the fearer was protecting Germany's working
men by October,
barely at 20 westerners remained in the city.
As the Imperial Army closed in,
rob cooled the other experts to his house and 14 responded among them.
The American doctor Robert Wilson.
We have to do something.
Rob told them that something was the Nanking Safety Zone.
Rob's plan with symbol,
despite being completely on arms.
The 14 westerners would unilaterally established a two and a half square mile
zone of neutrality in Nanking,
centered on Rob's house and the German school surrounded by white flags.
It would protect as many Chinese civilians is necessary.
When word got on to the advancing imperial army at dispatched to major archives.
You try and talk to this crazy German out of staying.
As rob later recalled,
Daca came to him in person and asked,
why in the devil did you stay?
Why do you want to involve yourself in our military affairs?
What does all of this matter to you?
You haven't lost anything here.
Looking at the major in the eye,
John Rob replied,
I've been living here in China for over 30 years.
My kids and grandchildren were born here and I'm happy.
I'm successful here.
If I had spent 30 years in Japan and were treated just as well by the Japanese
people,
you can be assured that in a time of emergency sop chances,
the situation China faces now,
I would not leave the site of the people in Japan.
The loyalty and rub statement,
it seemed to touch something in the major soul,
agreed rob could stay in the zone and there's no harm would come to him.
Unfortunately,
he said nothing about what would happen to any Chinese men that rob tried to
shelter is full,
gave way to a bidder,
wins a rob Wilson and others plastered nanking and posters telling citizens
about the zone Raul,
but even personally sent a telegram to and asking him to request the Japanese
acknowledged the zone as neutrality.
You can probably guess how that one went during the last few days before nanking
fell rather dramatically draped buildings in the zone with vast Nazi flags
hoping to determine our Japanese moments.
He had swastikas painted on walls,
deck his car out and party Regalia,
and took to wearing his uniform in public at the last moments and hangings may
or officially handed power over to rob and fled the city.
Now,
all robin,
the rest of his ex pats could do was wait on December the 11th,
heavy shelling.
It started as the bombardment increased.
The last Chinese in the capital flooded into the zone,
a quarter of a million people a converged on rob's property,
sleeping in ditches,
cramming themselves into tents,
climbing across one another just to be less than it was a wave of human
desperation,
unlike anything the westerners I'd ever seen.
Two nights later,
rob stood at a window with Dora watching the columns of flames to the south and
his garden below,
a crawling massive humanity wailed and screamed and begged for their lives as
the screaming and the shedding grew louder.
Rob finally snaps doning the metal helmet.
He's straight into the garden and screamed at the refugees to shut off.
He said that it was all going to be fine.
The Japanese would treat them fairly.
He was absolutely sure of it,
but his words,
they were lost in the din of the gunfire.
If they had carried,
it's unlikely anyone would have heated them.
It was December the 13th,
19,
37 and apocalypse.
It was in the APP.
As the flames roared,
Har,
the refugees huddle type together,
whatever happens next,
they knew that it would not be fine.
On the morning of December,
the 14th drawn rub awoke to a city blanketed in eerie,
calm,
daunting as uniform.
He ventured out into the cold,
empty streets beyond the zone,
wondering what he would find out that the roads of Nanking when littered with
corpses,
hundreds of civilians lay lifeless in the streets,
shot in the back as they flat bodies of women had been mutilated their vaginas
penetrated by Ben Blades.
On a street corner,
rob found a small contingent of Japanese troops losing a German cafe.
When he tried to stop them,
they laughed.
Well though they didn't harm rob,
they burned the cafe down.
Amused buys impotence as he returned from this unsettling expedition Rob Pasta,
but dragos bunch of 400 Chinese army regulars trying to retreat.
They were exhausted,
stumbling cutoff from safety.
The sight of them was so pitiful that rob told the soldiers that they could take
refuge in the zone on the one condition that they disarmed.
You still felt set in the imperial army would respect the zones neutrality.
That's an eit.
Diplomat,
Katsuaki Ozaki cooled on rob,
who was still acting as the mayor of the city.
He informed the gentleman that received intelligence,
that soldiers were in the zone.
He told rob that have to be arrested,
but he assured him that no harm would come to them,
unable to do anything else.
Rob agreed over the next few days,
Japanese fight as much through the zone looking for Chinese soldiers.
That method for detection was to look for calluses on my hands from firing
rifles to rob's Hora.
Thousands of young men were dragged from the zone.
The vast majority of them rickshaw drivers and workers who had been wrongly
identified.
They went lines up just outside and machine guns.
That bodies being dumped into ponds.
It was Joan Rob's first encounter with the brutality of the imperial army,
and it would not be his last as the tends December days,
past dream as began to drift into the zone of atrocities being committed outside
of it that were reports of Japanese soldiers going from house to house looking
for women's or rape age.
It was an austin issue.
There were reports of abuse.
Girls who were so young that the soldiers,
they type in their genitals so that they could fit in sight.
Them.
Boys were forced at gunpoint to rape their own mothers.
Men Right there,
I daughters,
women who'd been abused,
sexually tortured to death.
That genitals mutilated in the zone.
John Rob,
listen to these reports with a mounting Hora again and again.
He petitioned the Japanese offices who did nothing.
He Telegrams Gemini and demanded help,
but nothing came just before Christmas of 1937 something,
and then it seems to have snapped cuffs off from the rest of the wells in a city
that had gone mad.
Rob came to an inescapable conclusion.
If he wanted these atrocities to stop,
he would have to do something to stop them himself.
And this begins the inspiring chapter of John Rob's life.
The moments when he did something so mad,
so courageous,
he can only be called a hero with nanking burning around him.
Rob Dressed in his Nazi regalia,
left the relative safety of the zone,
completely unarmed.
He set out to save the city's residence.
This was nothing short of insanity.
Rob might have been protected by the imperial armies offices,
but it was very loose protection out on the streets.
He was just a man and a man without a gun who was staring down the bayonets of
Japanese soldiers,
and yet that is walked.
He did day off today as the southern crawled up into the winter sky,
rob would leave the zone listening to cries of help.
The telltale screams he would follow these streaks until he founds the marauding
soldiers storm right up to them,
shove his swastika armband in their faces and give them a brutal dressing down.
Amazingly,
it worked terrified by this German barking orders at them.
The soldiers they fled.
Rob would then take the girl that had been abusing out to his car and instruct
the driver to take her to the zone.
Then it's simply carry on walking,
looking for the next woman in trouble,
and then the next and the next.
Now it's really impossible to overstate just how crazy this was.
Rob could have been killed hundreds of times.
Yeah.
There was something that bounces authority,
something about the way he wielded as Nazi policy membership that put the fear
of God into the Imperial Army.
Elsewhere.
The Nazi swastika became a symbol of hate and rob's hands.
It became a symbol of hope.
Yet rob was not just some silent angel passing through the hell of Nanking.
He was a man capable of understanding the need for warmth for humanity.
He endora organized a birthday parties for children in the zone,
singing songs.
His death and demons clawed at the doors,
unsurprisingly,
most of the boys bone in the zone that winter.
They were named John Roberts.
He managed to win over his fellow western.
Dr Wilson was a staunch Anti Nazi.
You considered anyone who joined the party evil.
Yet even he grew to respect this one Nazi.
Even if he could never understand how rob could be so good while supporting
something that was so evil.
Six weeks off to the zones,
first refugees arrived,
the end,
it finally came in the dying.
It's not cold days of January.
The imperial armies.
Hi Andrea,
so had control over their forces in Nan king.
They marched into the zone and remove the refugees.
I collaborate to.
Government was set up as the rapes with stops.
In a cruel irony,
the imperial army triumphantly proclaims that that restored order to the city
today.
It's estimated that a minimum of 20,000 women were raped during the full of
nanking.
The widely accepted death dull.
It ranges from 100,000 to 300,000 prisoners of war were decapitated with swords.
They were blown up with land mines.
They were doused in petrol and set on fire in Japan.
Many still deny that the rape of nanking,
if it happens less than a month off to the zone,
was dismantled.
Rob Got a call from Siemens ordering him and him to Germany packing as many
films and photos of the massacre as he could.
He promised Wilson it spread word of the rape of Nanking back in Europe.
Then he boarded a plane with Dora and he left.
Now is it for John?
Rob,
as soon as he touched down in Germany,
he was arrested by the Gestapo for annoying.
They're Japanese allies.
It was in prison and it was only the intervention of Siemens CEO that saved him
reassigned to a lonely character position.
Rob Spent the next few years struggling just to make ends meet.
When World War Two ended in mid 1945,
his former standing within the Nazi party.
Sorry,
I'm arrested again.
This time by the allies put on trial.
Rob was only saved this time around by testimony from Dr Wilson left to rot in
jail for a year.
Rob was finally declared dean ossified in 1946 and he was released with a stain
of Nazi membership clinging to his soul.
The last years of John Rob's life saw him become unemployable as the post war
German economic miracle or living standards rise in the defeated nation,
John and slash or rob sank into help this poverty.
The only thing that kept them going and those harsh years were sent me regular
food parcels covered in Chinese writing that resound address.
It was always nagging.
Finally,
in January of Nineteen 50,
John,
rob keeled over and died of a stroke.
It was 68 by the time he died.
Rob Was A.
nobody a source of shame that came in Germany had been written out of the
Chinese history of hanging by the Julian stored communist party.
Those who'd been in Nanking,
they remembered him,
but the rest of the world they forgot
in the 19 nineties,
Iris Chang was researching the Nanjing Massacre.
She uncovered rob's diaries alongside stacks of documents relating to his
involvement in the safety side.
Piecing is incredible story together she managed to return his name to the wells
at large,
not long after the Chinese government paid to have rob's gravestone taken from
Berlin and reentered in Nanjing,
the modern city that John and Dora had known as king.
It was placed at the site of a gigantic memorial to the massacre.
After half a century,
rob had finally then returns to the country which had fought for and Ted loved
so much.
Nowadays,
it is estimated that rob's actions in nanking saved somewhere in the region of
250,000 lives.
Nearly everyone who made it into the zone.
By contrast,
the far more famous Oscar Schindler saved 1,200 people.
There is no doubt that schindler was a hero,
but rob,
he was something more.
He was a savior as history is good.
Nazi once wrote,
if you can do some good,
why hesitate.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We got brand new videos just like this several times a week,
so hit that subscribe button and you'll find out all about those and if you're
looking for something else to watch,
why not click on one of the videos on the screen now and as always,
thank you for watching.